-Pope Francis last week
released a new book
in which he says that gay people
shouldn't be allowed
to be priests.
One of our writers, Jenny Hagel,
is both gay and Catholic.
So she's here to comment
in a segment called
"I Have Some Thoughts On This."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, Seth.
This is Pope Francis.
When he first became Pope,
everyone was like,
"This guy's cool."
He hung out with
Leonardo DiCaprio.
He said all of our pets
are going to heaven.
And while other Popes
have driven around
in Mercedes-Benzes,
Pope Francis
drives a Ford Focus.
Which probably helps with
the whole celibacy thing.
[ Laughter ]
So the press dubbed him
"Cool Pope."
But here's the thing.
This guy's not cool.
This guy's homophobic.
If you're not Catholic,
you're probably thinking,
"Why should I care about this?"
And if you are Catholic,
you're probably thinking,
"What's the latest
I can leave my house
and still get to Mass on time?"
But we should all
care about this
because the Pope
is a world leader
who's giving people
permission to be prejudiced.
I'm gay and I'm Catholic.
When I came out,
some people in my family
told me that
I was going to hell.
They got that idea at church.
The same church that thinks
it's a good idea for 300 people
to drink out of the same cup.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Gross. That's gross.
One relative told me
that because I was gay
I wasn't fit to be a parent.
And I might not be,
but it's not because I'm gay.
It's because every time my
4-year-old wants to watch TV,
I lie and tell him
that the TV is sleeping.
[ Laughter ]
My son is lucky he has two moms
because that means
he has two people telling him,
"Come here. Come here."
[ Laughter ]
This guy isn't cool.
Do you know what's cool?
Telling LGBTQ people that they
are perfect and beautiful
and whole just the way they are.
This dude may seem harmless
because he's shuffling around
in a white robe.
But remember, white robes are
the official uniform
of people with bad ideas.
Exhibit A.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I went to
a Catholic high school,
and they sent me an e-mail
last week asking me for money.
I'll give you money when you
send a second e-mail
saying that everyone who went to
your school is created equal.
And when you send me
a letter jacket
even though I was the worst
player on your tennis team.
[ Laughter ]
I was voted "most ears."
Hate speech is hate speech,
and we need to call it out,
no matter where we see it,
even if it's in a Ford Focus.
[ Laughter ]
This has been
"I Have Some Thoughts On This."